[Musica]
sono una storica dell'arte e potrei
accompagnarvi tra due storie che sono
entrate nella mia vita arricchendola
importanti sono i protagonisti di esse
che con determinazione passione e un
pizzico di poesia hanno migliorato
l'identità del nostro territorio
due storie distanti e contrastanti in
cui è potentissima la forza generatrice
dell'arte
partiamo con la prima domenica 22
novembre mille di terremoto magnitudo
6.8 di 90 secondi colpisce la campania
tutti coloro che hanno vissuto questo
punto ricordano ancora
dov'erano con chi erano e cosa facevano
un gallerista napoletano lucio amelio
sente il bisogno di rispondere
all'evento catastrofico e sente che la
risposta che tutta nell'energia positiva
dell'arte da contrapporre all'energia
scatenata dal terremoto
ecco la scintilla che genera un sogno
gli anni 80 sono stati un periodo
cruciale dell'arte contemporanea in
italia anni in cui la spinta artistica
italiana ed europea riconquistava il
mondo e grazie a lucio amelio il primo
aprile del 1980
assistiamo a napoli a un episodio
importante per tutto il decennio un
incontro tra due artisti tra i più
emblematici del panorama internazionale
un incontro tra due culture quella
americana rappresentata da andy warhol e
quella europea rappresentata da joseph
boys
accade a in piazza de martini ad un vero
e proprio epicentro culturale si avvia
un cantiere internazionale che vedrà il
suo maggior sviluppo dopo la notte del
terremoto
infatti qualche giorno dopo lucio amelio
parte e si reca a new york per
raccontare a andy warhol il dramma che
si stava vivendo in campania 1 raccoglie
subito l'invito dell'amico e aderisce
con entusiasmo all'ambizioso progetto e
realizza il magnifico trittico con la
celebre prima pagina del giornale di
napoli il mattino del 26 novembre del
1980 interamente dedicata al terremoto
in essa è ben descritto tutto il dramma
tutta la la catastrofe è ben chiaro il
forte appello fate presto
tali grido da warhol e fortemente
esaltato amplificato tanto da essere
ancora oggi attualissimo dinanzi alle
molteplici catastrofi intanto boys
preferisce venire a napoli
assente il bisogno di vedere i luoghi
del sisma e personalmente raccoglie
vecchi strumenti di lavoro mai
abbandonati e con essi realizza la sua
opera terremoto in palazzo in cui
vediamo un tappeto di feltro vetri rotti
vasi di vetro sotto i tavoli e un nuovo
con la loro decontestualizzazione boys
ci invita a riflettere sulla precarietà
conseguente alla catastrofe arrivano
numerose tanti alte adesioni di diversi
tanti artisti inizia a formarsi una
collezione unica unica nel suo genere in
cui ciascun artista con il proprio
linguaggio riflette non solo sulla morte
sul terremoto sui drammi dell'uomo ma
sulla spinta propulsiva capace di
generare un rinnovamento su più livelli
aderiscono
67 artisti appartenenti alle principali
avanguardie artistiche pop art tanta
guardia minimalismo provengono
dall'italia dall'europa e dal mondo
accadere qualcosa di straordinario si
unisce il vicino l'italia napoli con il
lontano l'europa il mondo
lucio amelio non si ferma nella suo
dramma nella disperazione ma con la sua
passione con la sua tenacia riesce a
trattenere unito un territorio a dare
voce a una rinascita che si concretizza
in un bene inestimabile per l'intera
umanità lui stesso ci racconta le opere
della collezione terrae motus non erano
fatti per il mercato dell'arte ma erano
parte di una collezione magica che si
formava giorno dopo giorno
oggi l'intera collezione terrae motus e
custodita nel magnifico palazzo della
reggia di caserta a cui è legata con un
lascito testamentario per volontà di
lucio amelio venuto a mancare nel 1994
le settantadue opere insieme
testimoniano la forza generatrice
dell'arte e l'idea che da una catastrofe
può rinascere la vita e restituire
dignità ad ogni uomo
lucio amelio coglie nella scossa
l'opportunità per generare un sogno a
cui giunge con il contributo di tanti
passiamo adesso alla seconda storia
immaginiamo il cavalcare fiere al re di
napoli carlo di borbone
siamo nella metà del settecento qui a
napoli e con lui giungiamo nel luogo da
lui prescelto per l'allevamento della
razza del cavallo di pessano siamo a
carditello qui carlo e poi il figlio
ferdinando
si dedicano con profonda passione a un
ambizioso progetto che porta alla
realizzazione di un esempio innovativo
di fattoria modello la reggia di
carditello viene commissionata da
ferdinando a l'architetto francesco
collecini a quelli chiede esplicitamente
che il cuore del sito
doveva essere identificato con gli
edifici destinati all'allevamento dei
cavalli alla lavorazione dei prodotti
della terra all'agricoltura questa è una
peculiarità di molti siti borbonici la
fetta convivenza tra la vita dei
lavoratori e la vita dei giovani
ma a carditello accade ancora un
qualcosa di più importante ferdinando
dedica le maestranze più in vista della
corte noi troviamo i sì i tendaggi più
raffinati una ricca pinacoteca migliaia
di libri e l'arredamento più in voga
commissionato a prestigiosi mercanti
francesi ma l'unicità di carditello e
nella visione dei sovrani borbonici che
si concretizza nel centro sperimentale
di ricerca per la real azadi dei cavalli
la ricerca di stalloni e fattrici di
qualità si estende dal legno a tutta
europa e con l'allevamento latte di
bufala abbiamo una produzione di povo la
mozzarella che rappresentano l'oro
bianco grande fregio del nostro
territorio
carditello quindi un'opera d'arte viva e
feconda che in questi due secoli ha
vissuto momenti luminosi produttivi ma
anche momenti bui e di abbandono in
particolare dal ricordo della visione
dei giovani e dall incanto
delle delle sue opere noi giungiamo ai
giorni nostri
ai difficili giorni nostri in cui
arriviamo a una figura di un uomo un
uomo semplice tommaso cestone detto
l'angelo di carditello cestone un
agricoltore che spontaneamente decide di
occuparsi del sito mai abbandonato
vandalizzato e inizia a prendersi cura
di questo luogo
inizia a tagliare l'erba a lavare i
pavimenti a 2000 e anche in una roulotte
nel cortile del sito per meglio
custodirlo questo perché dopo l'unità
d'italia
il real sito di carditello passa una
gestione a dir poco lacunosa di un ente
parapubblico che poi fallisce e trascina
con sé il real sito fatto una scala
fallimentare rischiando quindi di
aggiungere in mani di speculatori ma nel
nonostante gli interessi dell'ecomafie
nonostante le difficoltà della
burocrazia che per 50 anni non era mai
riuscito a trovare soluzione
candy tello diventa bene pubblico viene
acquistata dallo stato nasce la
fondazione istituzionale poi che
recupera per il recupero e la
valorizzazione del del sito questo
accade perché a carditello ancora quella
forza e quella energia capace di
stringere a sé tutte le energie positive
necessarie perché ho voluto raccontarvi
questa storia perché è importante per me
perché se candy tello scompare la
sconfitta di tutti noi perché carditello
è un esempio importante per il nostro
territorio per il quale si auspica
ancora il complesso recupero ambientale
agricolo e culturale perché ciascuno di
noi è capace di sogni
e può generare qualcosa di straordinario
come i tanti protagonisti che abbiamo
incontrato stasera lucio amelio gli
artisti della collezione terrae motus e
le persone semplici come tommaso cestone
i volontari che ancora oggi
contribuiscono alla rinascita di
carditello perché occorre partire dalle
proprie terre o come portare nel futuro
la nostra storia il futuro è qui parte
da carditello
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]